hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm back in the second
installment of our daily Q&A series so
two days in still still every day so
that's a that's a good start I would say
question today is do I need to train
different muscles differently should I
train them in different rep ranges based
on fiber type breakdown I thought this
was a good question because I see this
get asked a lot I think this is a common
idea out there that particular muscles
are either predominantly type 1 muscle
fibers type 2 muscle fibers and because
of that you should train them
differently I am not really on board
with this idea for three main reasons
the first is that kind of in general
just as a starting point most muscles
don't really have one predominant fiber
type some notable exceptions there your
soleus one of the muscles in your calves
they are typically 85% Plus slow-twitch
type 1 fibers and some of your eye
muscles and also forearm muscles finger
extensors some of those are 80 90 % plus
type 2 muscle fibers but the majority of
the muscles in your body are essentially
pretty close to a 50/50 mix of type 1
and type 2 muscle fibers now there is
some inter individual variation there
some people are very very fast twitch
dominant some people are very very slow
twitch dominant in general but when kind
of dealing with averages so if you're
giving typical advice like most people
should train hamstrings with low reps
because they're predominantly fast which
that's something I hear a lot there's
really not good evidence to support that
hamstrings pecs Bell
slats there's quads there are multiple
studies looking at fiber types in those
muscles and a page with a breakdown of
all of those studies will be linked in
the description of this video and what
you'll see is that you know some studies
maybe 60/40 65 35 something like that
but the majority of studies for the
majority of muscles do kind of cluster
around a pretty even mix of type 1 and
type 2 muscle fibers so that's that's my
first problem with this idea one most
muscles aren't really predominantly type
1 or type 2 in general now the second
thing is people have this idea that you
can test your muscles to see if they are
predominantly type 1 or type 2 by taking
a particular percentage of your 1 rep
max and taking it to failure
so maybe 80% for as many reps as
possible if you get fewer than 8 reps
it's probably mostly fast-twitch fibers
because it gave out faster if you can
get more than 8 reps and it's probably
predominantly slow-twitch fibers that's
that's a test I see some people
recommending to determine what your
predominant fiber type in a particular
muscle is but there's a problem with
this as well this has been studied twice
I would need to look for these papers in
one of them though found no significant
correlation whatsoever between
predominant muscle fiber type and how
many reps people could get with a given
percentage of their one rep max the
other one did find a significant
correlation but if memory serves the
correlation coefficient was like point
4.5 which means the r-squared the
coefficient of determination was like
point 1 6 2 point 2 5 something like
that so in other words less than a
quarter of the variation in number of
reps people could get was explained by
fiber type itself
so they're they're very likely is some
relationship between the predominant
fiber type in a muscle and how many reps
you could get with a given percentage of
your one rep max if if you wanted to try
to test it like that but it's not a very
sensitive or accurate test so you know
odds odds would be pretty good that
unless you were just on the very extreme
end of the spectrum so you know maybe if
you were comparing your your finger
extensors to your soleus very very
predominantly fast twitch versus very
very predominantly slow twitch muscle
you know that very well may be a
meaningful difference but for pretty
much every other muscle in your body
that test would pick up a lot more noise
than signal so there's there's not
really a good practical way to know if
if one of your muscles are multiple if
your muscles are predominantly one fiber
type or not the only way to know for
sure is actually to get muscle biopsies
and if you want to go to a lab and have
people stick big needles and all of your
muscles and rip out little chunks of
your flesh all over your body then you
can know what's your predominant fiber
type is in each muscle but most most
people aren't going to do that so first
problem just in general most muscles are
a pretty even mix of fiber types - if
you're if you're concerned for yourself
that you know maybe some of your muscles
are predominantly type 1 or type 2 which
can certainly happen there's no easy
test for it simply seeing how many reps
you can get with a given percentage of
your 1 rep max
that may that may be that is probably
correlated with fiber type to some
degree but it's just not a very good
test it's not a very sensitive test
picks up a lot more noise than signal
and the last thing is even if you did
know that one particular muscle was say
much more type one dominance
whatever like let's say you go to a lab
you get your quads biopsied and normal
person's quads would be about 50/50 type
1 and type 2 let's say yours are 80%
type 2 does that mean that your best bet
would be to train your quads heavy
explosively you know titans types of
things that you would think would would
be better for type 2 fiber growth and
here's here's the real issue there's
really not good evidence that that would
make a meaningful difference studies are
all over the place here for the most
part what you tend to see is regardless
of rep range used type 1 or type 2
fibers tend to grow between 50 and 75
percent more than type 1 muscle fibers
do we really with almost any rep range
there are some studies that that could
be used to argue preferential type 1
versus type 2 fiber growth but there
they come out on on both sides of the
issue so one buy I know I'm going to
butcher this researchers name but
Schwing a I believe actually found that
high rep training that people would tend
to think would be better for type 1
fiber growth calls growth of type ii
fibers but not type 1 fibers whereas
lower rep training caused growth of both
types of fibers so that that would lead
you to believe that if you want type 1
fibers to grow those slow twitch fibers
you would need heavy training for that
and that lighter training is ineffective
for that which would run kind of counter
to this theory the but then there was
another study by mitchell that was
comparing working with 80% versus 30%
and found that overall muscle growth was
the same but that there was a lot more
type 1 muscle fiber growth slow twitch
muscle fiber growth with the lighter
higher rep training which would kind of
be in line with this theory so evidence
evidence is mixed and it's really really
inconclusive weather lighter higher rep
training is actually more beneficial for
type one slow-twitch muscle fiber growth
and whether heavier more explosive
training would be better for type 2 fast
twitch muscle fiber growth so just kind
of to recap I don't think when so okay
assuming that your primary goal is just
hypertrophy to get as jacked as possible
your best bet across the board is
probably just to train with a variety of
rep ranges regardless of what muscle
you're talking about the idea that you
should train different muscles
differently based on fiber type
breakdown
probably doesn't hold much water that
doesn't necessarily mean that you do
have to train every muscle exactly the
same that doesn't mean that there aren't
other factors that may influence how you
train particular muscles but to base a
lot of how you're training a muscle on
what its predominant fiber type is in my
opinion that doesn't hold very much
water because one most muscles that
you'd be dealing with except maybe your
soleus are probably going to be a pretty
even mix of type 1 and type 2 muscle
fibers in the first place - there's not
a good easy test - that has much
predictive power - to get a good idea of
whether a particular muscle is type 1 or
type 2 fiber dominant and the last thing
is even if you could know that the
evidence at this point is very very
mixed very unclear about whether high or
low rep training can specifically target
a particular fiber type so in short I
think I think it's an interesting idea
and I think it's a ripe area for
research that you know may either kind
of rain on this parade a little bit more
or validate it a bit more in the future
we'll just see as things move forward
but at this point when planning a
training program I don't really think
again for
hypertrophy specifically so this is not
about endurance training this is not
about power training this is just simply
about trying to get jacked because this
is where this idea is typically applied
for hypertrophy training I don't really
think this is this is something you
should really be using as a main guiding
principle for program design for most
people most of the time your best bet is
just going to be to use a variety of rep
ranges regardless all right guys so that
is the video if you liked it please like
and subscribe if you have training
questions that you want answered ask
them below and I will pick my favorite
one and answer it tomorrow and until
then enjoy your training and I will see
you in that next video